welcome back i'm not going to do a
series of videos on the trigonometric
identities so let's just uh review what
we already know about the trig function
so if we just write sohcahtoa
so
toa that tells us and we've actually
extended this with the unit circle
definition but if you watch those videos
you'll you'll realize that the unit
circle definition directly uses
sohcahtoa so we'll just stick with
sokatoa because i think it'll help
make some of what we're about to do seem
a little bit more straightforward and
we'll kind of verge on the unit circle
definition anyway so we know that sine
of theta
sine of theta
is equal to
opposite
over hypotenuse right so
cosine of theta
is equal to adjacent over hypotenuse
and then the tangent of theta
is equal to
opposite
over
adjacent so let's uh draw that out on a
right triangle we could do this with the
unit circle as well and it would it
would make sense and
let's see if we could find a
relationship between sine cosine and
tangent
there's my right triangle
let's call this theta
this is the hypotenuse h
this is the opposite side right opposite
of theta this is theta right here
this is the adjacent side right
well what do we know about the
relationship between the opposite
adjacent side and then the hypotenuse
what does the pythagorean theorem tell
us
oh yeah the opposite
this side squared plus this side squared
is equal to the hypotenuse squared so we
could write that down
a squared
plus
o squared is equal to the hypotenuse
squared right
and then you know this is this is just
an equation so if we want to we could
divide both sides of this equation by h
by h squared and so what do we get we
get
a squared
over h squared
plus
o squared
over h squared is equal to one right
and then i could rewrite that as
a
over h
squared
plus
o over h
squared is equal to 1.
now do these look at all familiar
well we have them here right this is a
over h
and this is o over h so we could just
substitute
so this is just cosine of theta
cosine of theta squared and this is how
you write cosine squared you could put a
parenthesis around the whole thing and
then square it but this is just the
notation people use
plus opposite over adjacent squares so
that's sine
theta
squared is equal to one so that's our
first trig identity so if you know
the sine of theta it's very easy to
figure out the cosine of theta right you
could just solve this equation right you
could if i know that the i don't know
let's say i know that the sine of theta
is
let's say one half right then what is
the cosine of theta
cosine of theta is what
well i know the sine of theta is one
half right so i would say
cosine
squared of theta
plus
sine of theta is one half so one half
squared
is equal to one
right so cosine
squared theta plus one fourth is equal
to one
and so we have cosine squared theta is
equal to three fourths
or cosine of theta
would be the square root of this right
we just take the square root of both
sides would be the square root of three
over two and you probably remember that
from our whole presentation on the
30-60-90 triangle so i just wanted to
show you a use of of the of of this trig
identity that it's usually written sine
squared plus cosine squared is equal to
one
so let's extend that one a little bit
let's just play with the the ratios and
see what else we can other
i guess identities we can discover
whoops
clear
image invert colors so we know that the
sine
squared theta
plus cosine
squared
theta
is equal to 1.
now one thing we could do is we could
divide
both sides of this equation by cosine
squared of theta and let's just see what
happens when we do that so if we say
cosine squared
theta right you have to distribute
across both terms
cosine
squared of
theta
and then
cosine
squared of theta
well what's sine squared theta over
cosine squared theta that's the same
thing as sine
of theta
over cosine of theta
right
squared plus this is 1
is equal to
1 over cosine
theta
squared right i just i just i mean 1
squared is 1. so i just rewrote it
so sine over cosine theta i think we
learned that already that's just the
tangent of theta
in case you actually haven't learned
that already think about it this way
sine is
opposite over
the hypotenuse right so that's opposite
over hypotenuse
and then cosine is adjacent over
hypotenuse so adjacent over hypotenuse
so then that equals
opposite over hypotenuse times
hypotenuse
over adjacent right just dividing by a
fraction is the same thing as
multiplying by its reciprocal that's all
i did
and that equals opposite over adjacent
right
so that equals opposite over adjacent so
that just says sine of theta over cosine
of theta is equal to tangent of theta
so sine squared theta over cosine
squared theta is tan squared theta
and then plus one
is one over cosine theta squared and now
i'm going to introduce a new
trig ratio and it's really just 1 over
cosine theta
so 1 over cosine theta and i'm going to
summarize this at the end just so it's
not too confusing is actually the secant
of theta and it's just another ratio
right the secant of theta instead of
being the adjacent over the hypotenuse
would be the hypotenuse over the
adjacent right it's just 1 over cosine
theta nothing famous nothing nothing
fancy here so secant of theta so that
equals
secant squared of theta i know it can be
a little overwhelming initially just
because i'm you know throwing out all of
these new terms secant is one over
cosine of theta but once you just play
around with these enough and get
familiar with the terms it'll make sense
it'll be a little more natural to you so
this could be you could view this as
another trig identity and actually in
case i don't even remember if i've if
i've taught it already
i mean you could view this as a trigger
identity although that's almost
definitional and then of course you can
in case i haven't done it already you
know you now know that sine of theta
over cosine of theta
is equal to tangent
of theta
and that's
right here was i guess you could say the
the proof of it so let me keep
introducing you to more things and if
this is really daunting maybe you just
can re-watch it and hopefully it'll make
some sense let me see
clear
image invert so what have we learned so
far we learned that sine
squared theta
plus cosine
squared theta is equal to one
we learned that sine
of theta
over cosine
of theta is equal to tangent of theta
we learned that
we learned that the tangent
squared of theta
plus one is equal to the secant
of theta
and here we let me actually write this
definition now the secant of theta
oops is equal to the secant squared of
theta sorry
and the secant of theta is just 1 over
cosine of theta
and this is something you really should
just memorize the secant is 1 over
cosine and if you're wondering what
one over sine is
1 over sine of theta
it's the cosecant
the abbreviation is csc
of theta and if you're wondering what
one over the tangent is
it's the cotangent
and you just might want to memorize
these and this this often confuses me
that
1 over the cosine is the secant but 1
over the sine is the cosecant so it's
kind of almost the the opposite right 1
over the sine has a co in it while one
over the cosine doesn't have the coin so
that that might help you uh remember
things
so i think that's all i have time for
now in the next presentation i'm going
to introduce you uh to a couple of more
trig identities see you soon